hello i'm going to be installing the
wsl windows subsystem for
linux on windows 10 this is the first
time doing it on this install
window so uh yeah just going to kind of
do it live and
and go with it where do we do them doing
the manual install
uh there's the website i just googled
wsl
and found this page so nothing super
special
there's a simplified install looks like
it wants you to join the window
windows and cider's program almost said
winders
yeah okay so we're gonna do the manual
one
all right so here we go uh powershell
it's like we're gonna have to do that so
let's go ahead and just
launch powershell because i could drag
my hotbar over here for a second
unlock drag it over so powershell
there it is so
step one enable the windows subsystem
for linux
you must enable it open power shell as
admin and run okay that open has
happened so let's do that again
there it is run as administrator
give it the privileges which apparently
blanked out the screen
that's fine okay so we got to go
d-i-s-m exe slash online slash enable
feature slash feature
name that whole thing slash all slash no
restart so i'm just going to copy that
over here right click right click paste
automatically so
cool hit enter and that was quick
okay there we go
tells us whatever the versions
okay then we recommend moving on step
two
but if you wish to only install wsl1 you
can restart your machine
and move to step 6. we're going to go to
wsl2
so we do need to check our version
number maybe this is a windows version
i believe you can just check that by
typing in system info
yeah okay so there's our system info
we're on build 19042 that's i think the
main thing we need to know
yeah i think we're okay i don't see
anything relevant there
oh it gives you steps i guess we could
just type
inver
there it is okay i don't think we're
on an old version or anything okay some
notes about versions in case you're
ruining
an older version i don't think this is
relevant to us
and we go to step three enable virtual
machine looks like we're doing a similar
thing
dsm online enable feature feature name
virtual machine platform slash all slash
no restarts let's go ahead and do that
paste
there we go step four
download the linux kernel package
there it is download the latest package
double click
okay this update only applies to
machines with the windows subsystem for
linux okay
so we got to go wsl set default version
2. we'll just copy that paste it
uh oh what didn't i like about that oh
it says restart
it it's on step three restart your
machine and complete wso install so
we're gonna reboot
okay we are back after the reboot it did
do like a little windows
update type thing when i was rebooting
you know the whole percent
thing it's like 30 don't shut off your
computer and so on
okay so we should be able to continue so
let's go powershell
and we'll do this default version thing
now and see if that works
looks good okay i
assume this linux kernel update took
uh i guess we'll find out because
uh you know i did it without restarting
or whatever but i think it's okay
so next step six install your linux
distro of choice
open the microsoft store i've got it
right here
and select your favorite linux distro i
think we're just going to go
real simple for now and go ubuntu
probably go with a stable one i don't
know there's 20 long term support
18.404 long term support
definitely want to go long-term germ
support lts
so we're just going to go with 20.
and let's just make sure there's nothing
special that we're missing
okay there's there's a whole bunch of
different ones we could get we're gonna
stick with ubuntu
it's pretty well supported so sounds
good to me
sign in nope not signing in
you own this app okay
okay it's installing
so i'm gonna close powershell for now
okay let's go ahead and hit uh i don't
know let's pin it to start sure
there it is let's click it
uh-oh it says wsl 2 requires an update
to its kernel component
so what do i got to do here
okay it was probably this linux kernel
thing it probably didn't take so i
didn't do the restart so let's do that
again
i've already got the download let me
just find that
so there it is i'm just going to go
install
okay i didn't get the warning this time
okay yeah prompted for admin rights
that's why it blinked out
there we go go ahead and install that
that was quick so now we should be able
to run
ubuntu yeah it looks good
very cool so well yeah we're gonna play
around with this a little bit
if you're following along i will put all
these links down below
it finished and it's asking for a
username i'm just going to do mje which
is my initials
and it wants a password i'm glad it's
not revealing it
okay it says installation successful to
run a command as
administrator use sudo yeah i already
know this okay
man pseudo root for details welcome to
ubuntu
tells you where the documentation is
management support
and some more other details but it looks
like we're in here
so i'm just going to try something i'm
going to close this and i'm going to
relaunch it
and just see what it does cool
we're good so let's go apt
search github so
get uh there's a lot of stuff
let's go sudo apt-get install it
put in our password
git is already the newest version so it
comes with git pre-installed what else
do i need i want
make looks like it's installing make
cool i think that's all i need for
well there's a program i want to work on
that's
linux only and that's kind of my main
reason for installing it so basically
the video is over at this point if
you're just watching for the install but
i'm just going to play around with
cloning something and seeing if it runs
i want to see what directories we have
print working directory
i'm going to make a directory maker
and i'm just going to call it like
repost
and want to go into repos i'm going to
go get clone
uh let's see what is it http
so this is the program i want to work on
cloning
it's linux only program we're going to
go into it cd dm power
boom that easy yeah okay all right what
would we get branch see what branch
we're on
should be master yeah i made this repo
for all the
get changes because now the master
branch is called
main they changed that recently
okay so i'm just going to run make
see if it works
oh i don't have the c plus plus stuff
installed g plus plus
command not installed so let's go sudo
apt-get
install g plus plus uh oh we got unable
to fetch
okay i bet we need to do something like
uh sudo apt update maybe
and just get the latest updates because
we've probably got like old
repos and stuff like that
okay 26 packages
can be upgraded sudo apt upgrade
yes okay so i guess this is one of the
first things you probably want to do
once you get linux installed on this
it's just do with the app
upgrade makes sense
so now let's do sudo apt-get
install gcc
much better much better so that was it
and now we'll go
make oh real quick just make sure yeah
we're still in the same
directory
and it seems to make file right there so
yeah i wrote this program so i
pretty much know what to do but it says
gc2
plus still not found so i guess we're
going to have to go
sudo apt get install g plus
a little bit more stuff there run make
again
oh it looks happy now i predict work see
how i have the l
boost file system yeah i thought that
would happen it wouldn't find boost so
we need to go
uh at search it's usually like
live boost
we'll just do live boost to see what
kind of options we have
so it's like live boost dash file system
dash
dev probably dash file system
dash dab let's try that there it is
okay so instead of search for this time
i'm going to go
sudo apt get install
live boost file system dash tab
get that installed make
and we have a success and we'll now see
the binary right on the root there
that's how i have it build
so we should be able to just run it with
dot slash dmpower
just like you would on linux and boom
there we are so yeah in case you're
confused about what this program is well
it's just a program i wrote for linux to
build dungeons and dragons characters
and
some other tools for dming
so let's just try building a character
create the first character
let's just go random
random level five character boom
okay let's see what we created it
created
gola the whatever the chicken person
sorcerer let's let's see what the
character she gave it
the random stuff sorcerer 5 criminal
background
there's the stats hey it actually dumped
charisma is the high stat that's
randomized so it doesn't always give you
the stat you want
but yeah sorcerers and dungeon dragons
want charisma
and it looks like yeah so this would
like be a decent npc to just throw at
somebody or throw in a game
you know so that's kind of the point of
this tool
uh let's just go save work i want to
make sure the save works on the
subsystem
save save as test
there we go looks like saved properly
let's get out of here and let's go to
generate loot make sure that works
we're going to generate some loot
for a treasure layer
so say your players rated something and
they get
potentially all the treasure in a
dungeon or layer
this is what you would roll according to
the dm guide
say they're level five-ish so we'll do
option two
have the system roll for you yes so yeah
you can randomly put in or you can
like manually roll dice and put the
number in or you can just
let the randomizer do it so we're gonna
let the randomizer do it
and there's what they would have found
copper silver gold
platinum a bunch of gems
and an oil sharpness cool
all right let's try maybe creating a
wizard spell book how many first level
spells
five second level four three two one
let's go down the line
and zero for these how many pages
needs at least 35 according to the
number of spells that are in it so we'll
say it's a 60 page
spell book what's made out of i don't
know we'll just say letter
and there we go new spell book there's
the list of spells
randomly picked super useful
for when your players come across the
spell book and you're like oh pam now i
got to figure out what spells are in it
as a dm
that's incredibly tedious so with this
tool it's just like there you go has
these spells
and there we go well there's some other
tools in every word
looks like everything works fine
settings
we got a few things there
other tools got a few more things there
i think those are all just charts and
stuff
so not a not a huge deal
uh cool
all right well i just want okay so i
exited
and i want to run it again and make sure
it loads yep it did
load auto loads the last file
make sure the character's still there
yep goal is still there
so you can create as many characters as
you want and save them in a file
a lot of options here i'm not going over
everything
but i'll show one last thing it's that
you can level up
characters so there's the character
sheet
and then we can there's some options i
guess this is not very clear i could
probably make this a little clearer
but we'll go level up
current levels five choose a higher
level we'll go level six
set source or details okay so something
changed
did there were no options to select so
it's on some levels in dnd
you don't really get to pick anything
you might just gain like some hit points
and a new ability or something
but we'll go ahead and get out of there
view let's take a look at gullah now
she's level six and uh
not entirely sure what changed
probably got a new class ability
probably more sore serve points
okay cool
and let's see let me check
settings auto save is off so
yeah auto save
so if i quit now without saving
should still be level five the way it's
written to the drive
but let me just test that
exited tm power
take a look view yeah back to level five
so let's turn auto save to on
which is you know i don't like it on
personally
i don't know i'm mixed here because if
you mess something up
you can always just quit if you don't
have auto save on
but there are other options too for
example when you view a character
you use this export option that
writes out a copy of the sheet as it is
so if you go level up or something
you'll still have that level five
sheet as a backup
but you got to go into your files to
find that
like wherever this installed
linux basically where does it install
linux
let's take a look
so we're going to look at where is wsl
installed
looks like it's local app data packages
root tfs root fs okay so we want to go
to
our local app data i think
so that's a good thing to know because
it should be
in users my name there
it's a hidden file so we got to go view
hidden items
app data local
what's the rest of that packages
i'm not seeing packages there it is
packages
and then a package oh no so what's this
one named
i guess it would be this con canonical
one
huh okay well that's a little tricky
because it looks like it's gonna have a
weird name i'm guessing it's this
because it starts with canonical
local state yeah local state ext4
uh oh it's in use okay so it can't read
it but i'm pretty sure that's this
like how would anyone ever figure that
out if they didn't know you know
yeah canonical group limited dot ubuntu
224 yeah that's got to be it
so i guess we would have to close out of
this to open that
but yeah we should be able to find that
in our exports folder
so let's just go ahead and
let's add it edit gola
level up level up to 7 this time
go back and it auto saved let's see it
saved there
so let's back out quit
and what do we do wait i think
i don't know we'll just close this close
let's see if we can open up this
drive now okay so i kind of want to know
like how do you open
these files on your
actual drive because i don't necessarily
want to have to go
like this every time
but it's fine we'll do it we'll go back
into repos
we're going to dm power take a look here
there's a folder called exports
cd exports there it is there's our level
5 sourcer
so we could open that up probably visual
studio
code see if that does it
yeah it lets us cool
and there's that written out character
sheet of level five
so you can always write out your
character at any time with this program
oh wanted me to install this i don't
actually want to do that right now okay
so we're going to close that
that's pretty cool if you don't want if
you don't want to open it with code you
can always go
cat and do it like that and i'm pressing
tab to auto complete in case you don't
know
so cat will show it all too okay one
last thing i want to do
you want to work on dm power for example
or five one and two it's an open source
project so anyone could
so if someone's on windows and wants to
make it better or update it with a new
book that came out for d indeed
or something you can install visual
studio code and all the c
plus stuff like i did and then you can
just go code
dot which will open visual studio code
on this directory
it's installing vs code server for x64
which uh okay all right
and there we go there's uh everything
the whole structure
we can go into source here and edit
whatever file and recompile
so yeah i wrote all this uh years ago
when i was in college
and playing d d a lot and working just
all the stuff received well
i'm not going to do that right now okay
but pretty cool pretty cool stuff
so last thing i want to do here is just
install
the windows terminal
totally optional
so i think that's just in the microsoft
store
let's let's take a quick peek at this
before
and ape enables tabs to switch between
linux
powershell etc so you can just have all
your stuff going at once
multiple linux command lines oh you're
gonna have multiple versions of linux
running that's super cool
okay so let's just go search and we'll
go terminal
see what we find there's the windows
terminal click it
get
don't already click this get there we go
no thanks to the sign
in
install no okay it's already installing
i didn't need to click install
sure we'll pin it to start let's go
ahead and take a look at it
launch it there there we are
so how do we launch linux
do i go to wsl
yeah there we go that was it and it
looks like it
launched it launched wsl on my
home drive on my on my windows system
so this is uh this is a whole another
animal i
i don't actually know what i'm doing now
yeah i think i'm just going to call it
here because i'm just kind of poking
around
and i'm sure i'm going to learn a lot
more on my own but i don't want to drag
out the video with
not much going on or my trial and error
etc etc
so thanks for watching hopefully you've
enjoyed or learned something or
maybe just thought this was interesting
or whatever but uh
yeah see you guys in the next video matt
from codetech tutorials over and out